[Musique]
alba j'ai cueilli des pivoines en
pensant à toi j'ai pris des blanches
comme ton nom et comme ton idéal et de
rouge comme tes combats
voilà ce que c'est qu'une n'avait alors
elle passe comme ça comme ça et elle
dessus dessous il ya atteint lui
remettez à pisser 1 alors tu sais
comment ça marche
voilà un souvenir c'est lourd 1 c'est du
bois dur et alors qu'un tueur en soit ça
à la figure je vais maintenant une une
camarade de maman une campagne de
travail qui en avait reçu notionnels est
bien à cause de ça j'ai jamais voulu
apprendre à tisser jeune femme avait
traumatisé en établit encore là perdu
l'oeil elle l'a reçu en pleine figure et
ils s'étaient tous six heures tu vois
cette photo là et bien tous sont tous 10
heures excepté moi même mon frère est
devenu 10 heures mais moi j'ai toujours
eu peur je pense que le plus récent des
plus anciennes je peux les voir jouer
lors de l'action oui toxines je fais que
ça je toujours restée d'un nouveau
cordage
nos profondes antoine est un symbole
d'une nation tout le temps mais je me
mets machine pierre je sais pas c'est si
bon chemin
john eales console atari talent son
héritage immatériel
vous récupérez sélectionné plus précis
mais les données politiques et avant le
jour de la mort et bien non enseignantes
édifice
[Musique]
on était très proches parents enfants
tôt leur vie et l'arrivée il était très
unie d'abord entre eux tout ce qu'ils
vivaient ils le récupèrent la maison mon
éducation politique se fait comme ça sur
le tas par ta famille par ma famille oui
devoir vivre les miens puis j'avais
assisté à cette époque c'était se
réveille pour l'état vienne qu'il y
avait eu à la fin elle a pendant la
guerre et puis à la fin de la guerre
admettons mais anglaise étaient tous
s'étaient tous des militants alors est
comment tu vois tout à l'évolution du
parti depuis on peut pas dire que ça va
bien mais moi je garde espoir parce que
je dis que c'est pas possible les aider
sont justes et je pense qu il y aura une
évolution comme arrivera quand même à
s'en sortir parce qu'ils y habitent
solutions il y en a pas d'autre c'est
nous qui avons raison
est ce qu'il ya eu des moments au cours
de deux tons activités militantes ou de
ta vie où tu t'es senti en désaccord ou
est-ce que tu as toujours été c'est à
dire qu'il ya des choses que je n'ai pas
prouvée japp approuvé l'exclusion de
militants que pour en reprenant excluait
les militants surtout à mon époque
surtout à l'époque où moi j'aime bien
des régimes communistes
il y avait déjà été il y avait des
discussions que je profonde de ce même
pas mais je trouvais que s'il était
sincère pourquoi les exclure s'était pas
on a chacun sa façon de voir ce sont des
choses qui sont des différences de
tactique des différences de façon de
penser de voir les choses autrement
mais qu'on conserve le même idéal je ne
souffre pas quitté le parti pour ça donc
on sait qu'il est sur la bonne voie
bonjour bonjour savez je perds un mythe
alors je vous laisse mes clés et
veillerez sur ma maison
d'accord
il y avait beaucoup de familles
italiennes c'était le père qui prenaient
l'initiative qui se faisait naturalisé
toute la famille et mon père je sais pas
mon père était très attaché à son
village il voyait toujours de retourner
alors jugé pas nécessaire de les amener
son propre passé ça s'est fait comme ça
mais nous on sentait pas de différence
ça ne manquez pas le fait on se
considère ailleurs le viennois on était
en avait grandi à vienne vienne c'était
notre pays on sentait pas 7 7 7 après la
guerre que nous avons demandé la
nationalité
française avec mon frère mon mari et moi
et elle nous a été refusé les raisons
politiques certainement
cet iphone
sow
il ya quelque chose à propos des
élections en italie
le chef de l'udc de l'opposition de
droite italienne a définitivement refusé
tout débat télévisé avec son adversaire
de centre gauche française qu'européenne
avant les élections législatives du 13
mai il a affirmé que francesco l'hôtel
n'était pas digne de lui
[Applaudissements]
le man down
les attentions quoi dire
ce sens et signifierait en drôle de
passage à droite
surtout que les italiens avec un retrait
néo fascistes italiens
je ne sais pas
sommes toujours venu avec mes parents
votais en italie
et comme je peux pas voter en france je
viens voter en italie même si c'est
qu'une fois c'est toujours une voix
puis maintenant c'est l'europe alors
quand vous tard en italie ou en france
pourrait qu'on vote
la balle a ricoché
je suis assez d'accord avec l'europe
mais c'est une autre europe que je
voudrais je voudrais l europe une bonne
organisation nous d'europe de l'europe
des travailleurs de l'europe des peuples
et pas être sous la mainmise du des
capitalistes comme celle temps ça me
fait un peu peur pour ça parce que
mais enfin je pense que leur hôte est
utile si on veut défendre ses idées
un peu
[Musique]
m
le compris ce qu'est ma biche aubry fait
venir j'ai apporté beaucoup
voilà le mot pérouse c'est une autre en
effet complet avec la france ou l'italie
regardez la suisse et les com - vie avec
tous ses souvenirs
et ben voilà les maisons les habitudes
celles ci on a passé des jeux au biberon
à 14 et bien et même si cette maison
elle avait été laissée à leur père à sa
désunion du chat du château la saq
allait à l'erreur et lisse à l'acquérir
national te papa à leur demandant
d'annuler son grand père mon vista
je ne peux pas me sens que je vais être
[Musique]
la place
[Applaudissements]
avant la guerre est un événement qui
s'est passé qui m'a marqué puisque je
m'en suis toujours rappeler c'est
l'assassinât de jaurès mon père
travaille et maman à ce moment là elle l
avait informé frère de petits elle
travaillait pas et alors le soir vers le
belle journée d'été on aller à sa
rencontre
c'était un petit chemin de campagne quoi
est ce soir là et de l'arrivée par leur
nous retournons à la maison je la voyais
qui est engagée c'est pourquoi pas peur
bien pas elle me dit massive est remis à
venir et puis quand il est arrivé il
avait l'air triste et maman lui dis moi
j'étais inquiète à leur et lui dit mais
on s'est réuni à la porte des usines
parce qu'on a tué le jaurès demain et à
grève générale et et moi je cette
impression de tuer tuer
je lui dis tu es tu aimais comme le
lapin que j'avais vu tu en as tu un
livre icône latin c'est loin bas de la
laissez pas en voiture on sent par
contre mais c'est tellement ça fait une
bonne heure de cheveux groupe
d'ailleurs ils iront prépa midi ils
portaient leur périple des fois il
allait faire la pole est ce aux
alentours et se réunissait plusieurs il
dispose en poney c'était la vie rustique
ici
et mon père économie réelle et elle est
ancienne de khalis alors beaucoup
multiples des femmes avaient beaucoup
dans notre coin beaucoup manifesté
contre la guerre
à
de même temps
alors si fameux tee shirt gratuit des
bons viaggio avaler morceau a les mains
propres à la base
j'm'en les montagnes
j'étais tombé si bas
les jours puis j'ai un souvenir mais qui
m'a été transmis permettant à part une
de mes tantes qu'elle me dit ça m'étonne
pas que tu sois une liste parce que je
ne devais quand tu étais petit était
venu avec nous et avec nous une réunion
mais la guerre il avait décoré la salle
avec des portraits de militants et il y
avait et à la manche avait vu car le max
sur des cartes postales que pas parler à
la maison je compte mon doigt dessus
puis je dis regarde karl max alors il y
avait là militants péquistes qui
venaient de l'extérieur elle regarde ce
petit bout de chou là qui dit que tu
préfères le marx alors je la regarde que
j'ai dit oui je me connais cette mamie à
mon papa je suis allé à l'école assise
âme et jeu
je me rappelle d'abord j'étais très
entourées table permettant ma grand mère
maman c'était tous des femmes les hommes
étaient à la guerre alors c'était une
ambiance traite de mousse tu sais très
endettés en été et chouchouté l'alto et
j'avais trouvé les maîtresses dur les
lisseurs les avait sauvés tueur et puis
je sais pas si elle avait déjà les noirs
nous comptons moi mes parents m'ont et
n'était pas catholique donc j'étais pas
je n'avais pas été baptisé et n'en
voulait certainement pour ça
nous avons quitté le hameau et nous
sommes allés chez ma grand-mère quand
mon père est parti à la guerre et pas
grand souvenir je sais que ont manqué de
beaucoup de choses l'armistice était pas
signer encore mais enfin on sentait
quand même qu' il y avait des bruits de
pets et là un bon père il était malade
et la popu reprendre son travail de 10h
alors il lui fallait il fallait delerm
de le grand air tout à l'heure à son
confrère nous propose un lieu des sites
et des amours avec moi la montagne il
fait et c'est en mais petit à petit les
affaires allaient pas très bien en ce
qu'on vivait difficilement lors il y
avait un de ses amis qui étaient en
france que je lui ai proposé de lui
envoyer une lettre d'appel à ce moment
là on a moyen d'être d'appel on était
sûr d'avoir du travail en arrivant alors
il a accepté en accord avec maman et les
parties
[Musique]
je me rappelle de pas que ce que lui m'a
raconté c'était le 28 octobre 1922 et
c'est un moment il a juste le train
arriver à modem qu'il a appris que sony
avait fait la marque seront donc qu'il
avait
et il était en italie la de propositions
de l'état italien et après que vous avez
tous partis ça a continué la répression
ils sont allés chez nous la mapar teum
en commun dans la maison qu'elle
habitait avec mon grand père ils ont
sorti les livres ils ont brûlé les ont
tout saccagé leurs prêts il était
catalogué comme un anti fasciste et ils
pouvaient pas retombé et un thé avec
mussolini l'a jamais pu retourner
[Musique]
alors nous a demandé de venir le
rejoindre dans maman mon frère et moi il
nous sommes venus de moi après mon arrêt
du travail aussi nous sommes amenés à
l'école et voilà
[Musique]
on a connu un accord de la france
s'était pas c'était pas le pérou mais
enfin on vivait on vivait pendant points
il y avait pénurie de logements et on
atterrissait mon pouvais tu vois c'est
là toute la fenêtre du troisième étage
enfin c'est une fenêtre est fermée
maintenant elle donne seulement sur le
palier et là il y avait un robinet d'eau
mais qui n'était pas dans notre
appartement
vous prenez l'eau et c'était une cuisine
avec une pièce avec deux lycées mais
oublie mais je me souviens qu'il y avait
qu on entendait le soir 20 pour
l'humanité dans la rue on attendait une
compet ont passé la tête à travers les
barreaux et on voyait il y avait un
monsieur qui est passé a écrit l
humanité l'humanité
mais après il dit est dit le journal de
jaurès alors moi je dis mère mon père
dit papa il ya un homme qui a crié
jaurès 1 dans la rue alors mon père il
m'a dit oui parce que c'est lui qui
avait forme de l'humanité elle m'avait
expliqué
[Musique]
fusionner cette société dont il a hérité
avec c'est notre père il laisse ses
d'histoire ancienne très sensuelle on
n'a jamais dit ça
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'école le met bien y
aller
la cour était plus grande parce qu'il y
avait pas ce bâtiment ont la cote et le
4e temps c'était de la pure battu les
petites mes camarades me faisait dire
des moore et puis je n'arrivais pas à
distinguer 8,2 vite je disais vite
captifs avaient 18 sur les amuser mais
j'avais une petite camarade qui est
d'accompagner tout le temps quand je
rentre à la maison et puis elle me
disait qu'elle m'aimait bien mal me dis
qu'est-ce que c'est dommage que tu sois
italienne
je suis allé à la maison puis jeudi un
moment d'une maman c'est mal d'être
italien il me dit mais non des italiens
parce que tu es né en italie c'est pas
mal je peux plus mal que des français
alors ça m'avait un petit peu rasséréné
puis après je lui dit jeudi sur tu lui
diras que tu l'aiment bien alors après
je lui étais tu sais moi je t'aime bien
s'appeler nelly j'ai dit tous emilie moi
je t'aime bien quand même des françaises
j'ai passé mon certificat d'études en 24
j'ai eu la chance de réussir et après
d'après je suis rentré en apprentissage
on avait depuis toujours on me disait
que ce serait une couturière je mets
d'ailleurs beaucoup coudre et on m'avait
mis chez une couturière ou l'ambiance je
retrouvais un petit peu dans cet atelier
l'ambiance de mon école de berne italie
alors j'ai pas voulu rester
c'était pour ya celles qui est conquis
il rentrait en apprentissage c'était
presque tous des filles de conversion
des contremaîtres des et moi j'étais une
simple fille devriez alors ils avaient
pas l avais j'étais en dessous d'elle
une fille de voiliers comprenait pas que
ce soit là je pouvais pas leur
expliquent leur expliquer que les
ouvriers balles et les autres mais enfin
moi je le saint-père mois moi j'aimais
bien mon milieu ouvrier
je mets le mieux où vit le mes parents
et toute cette ambiance de
de textile dans le dans lequel nous
vivions c'est pour ça que je suis allé
le textile
on va aller voir ça vous arrive de 1900
le chômage complet oui nous soussignés
certifiant que par suite du manque de
travail
le mazel de les strass et les honneurs
employés dans nos ateliers comme
testeuses du 1er janvier 1900 ce joueur
est un chômage complet 40 un seul cela
que j'ai fait
j'avais fait le tour de toutes les
usines et jade est partout mais il n'y
avait pas de temps ci avait pas de place
en plus il y avait déjà du chômage pour
celles qui étaient les pensées a duré
pendant quelques années j'étais
répercutée dans le monde entier cette
crise de 29 euros
depuis la presse le monde repris sly
alors j'ai demandé à rentrer du sinn
soccer et alors là je suis resté cinq
ans cependant ces 5 1 qui a vu ce qui
c'est grande gueule de tendue dont un à
nathalie dans toute la france le départ
de la grève c'était on est bien le
départ de puel c'était là la porte
puisque toujours on est ici tout le
monde était descendu des ateliers et
alors on avait discuté devant la porte
et les ouvriers nous attendait alors on
a dit bon on n'a pas obtenu satisfaction
aux parents gré alors on est tous montés
dans les ateliers parce qu'on était en
avesnois du travail pour se charger et
puis après on est redescendu et quand on
est arrivé là ici avec les tisseuses et
elle ne descendait pas il y avait trois
dvd avec nous mais j'ai dit qu'est ce
qu'elles font et mettait dehors les
patrons sous son nez sur la porte pour
nous intimider
alors on désinfo dre aller les chercher
mais personne se sortait le courage de
passer devant les patrons sédunois
allez au milieu des métiers meurent
avait arrêté les machines puis on nous a
dit mais qu'est ce que vous faites vous
demander de parole des autres sont en
dedans maintenant il faut parti alors en
2d ce mur mais tous sauvés quand j'étais
remonté alors pour m'habiller alors lui
les contours nets ne savait pas ce qui
se passait alors comment ça marche
et bien chez qui veut pas entendre
raison alors j'ai dit et je sais c'est
ton tube baisser le salaire on a déjà de
petits salaires c'est vrai que le
pouvoir d'achat était faible
alors il nous avait dit comme argument
que les oeufs et les pcb sur le
printemps ça mais que ne comptait pas de
il ya autre chose à manger alors j'étais
tout excité comme ça alors elle me dit
mais c'est pas vrai mais tu est miss
talent je me suis arrêté je vais
regarder puis jeudi communiste moi je
dis ça se peut il ya eu de la répression
mais on a on a quand même repris tout le
monde mais au fur à mesure que nous
partions ou pour une chose à l'autre les
garçons qu'elle est au service militaire
et des ronds connais pas tu vois moi je
suis parti je suis sûr que moi je suis
jamais demandé à revenir mais je sûr que
j'aurais alors contre m je suis parti il
m'a dit tu sais je te regrette beaucoup
si jamais un jour tu as besoin de
revenir tu peux revenir à leur jeu et
dévie vous vous dites comme ça mais pas
de patrons parce que je sors bien
comment ça évidement verra on verra
pis j'aurais eu besoin de revenir mais
j'ai pas voulu revenir du travail
ailleurs
[Musique]
un soir ils avaient encerclé la place de
l'hôtel de ville on pouvait plus on
pouvait plus sortir les rookies a tué
n'était étaient toutes prises par les
gardes mobiles et là vous allez nous
tabasser est loyal je sais pas le même
marchisio qui était un vieux résista qui
équipe qui était réfugié politique qui
avait l'expérience des grèves vins
d'italie où tout est là il a pris un
gros une grosse pierre et puis solution
les rideaux de fer de magasins il a fait
un bruit de la rouler ça fait un grand
bon ça a effrayé les chevaux alors les
choses se sont dispersés çà fait comme a
pu s'évacuer en a qui se dispersent et
comme ça
[Musique]
alors c'était très bien merci aux
jeunesses communistes j'étais au début
j'étais la seule fille j'étais la seule
fille entends des paiements et à ce
moment là j'étais financer donc avec
celui qui devait par la suite mon mari
il était interné l'été de turin il
n'était bien acquis à nos idées mais il
n'était pas il était pas mais du temps
nous ne sommes mariés en octobre autres
entrants il faisait très froid il
approuve la demande en terres qui doit
fait un foisonnement de sang il est
décédé au bout de 48 heures je suis
retourné chez mes parents je suis resté
longtemps à m'en remettre je n'ai plus
que une épave
je n'avais plus goût à rien
[Musique]
l'entre-temps mon frère a adhéré au gc
et on dit chez les copains et cécile
sont ils s'étonnent que tu emmènes pas
que j'adore j'ai commencé il ya déjà
repris dans l'activité
il y avait un peu plus petites sections
socialistes ou monterrey est aberrant où
ces dames il y avait beaucoup de copains
de chez nous de la même région
c'était politique si tu veux mais
c'était aussi familial l'aïe a mené chez
les jeunes photo là d'un premier mec il
y avait un petit un petit guinguette
tout c'est de deux campagnes qui étaient
venus aussi ternes italienne syriens
disent elles dimanche
ça fait quand même un semblant de vie
collective à vienne y avait aussi un
anarchiste vent oui il y avait les
anarchosyndicalistes qu'on appelait ici
on pratiquait beaucoup d anarcho
syndicaliste mais chez nous on n'avait
pas cette il avait plutôt de l'unité
avec les anarchistes communistes
socialistes y avait plutôt un semblant
d'unité chez li na li en parce que cette
chanson là j'ai passé plus a eu
l'occasion de l'entendre lundi à lugano
belle tu l'as entendu de la connaît non
je l'air assez rare à cassette je te
ferai écouter était bien cette chanson
le cdc des anarchistes italiens qui
s'était réfugié en suisse est bien en
suisse un jour on les a chassés
la vie ici
[Musique]
c'est à dire oui contre on y avait 30 45
la préparation du front populaire et le
développement des organisations les
élections de 36 mon frère me disait
toujours ça a été les plus belles années
de ma vie parce qu'alors les congés
payés nous sommes allés au pyla et peu
après tous les dimanches en sortait du
seuil en porter le casque honteux mais
manger d'un cottage ou l'autre on
vivrait ou un muret puis on était jeune
il
et puis un jour j'allais aussi lg je
rencontre lui c'est une camarade qui
était logistique était justement une
étudiante de communiste aimé l'homme en
tant qu a déclaré la guerre à attaquer
leurs étudiants ce mal et lan avait les
larmes aux yeux
on a travaillé beaucoup pour la guerre
d'espagne
on s'est mises à tripoter tri gâté en
tricoter des copies et puis on ne la
prend pas garde pour la constitution des
brigades internationales tout ça pour le
beaucoup de jeunes qui déjeunent sur
tous les médias espagnols qui rejoignent
et tous peur républicaine on a travaillé
énormément mais enfin ça a été quand
même quelque chose qui nous a frappés en
plein de joie parce que nous on est
amené juste de d'avoir les congés payés
les 40 heures tout ça et on a bien que
partout il avait invité
en attendant la contacter n'en était pas
c'est tout
il y avait un jeune qui était de lyon
comme il y est mort d'ailleurs le pauvre
entre était un très bon copain
on connaissait le met souvent aux
sorties avec nous
il est parti à long terme il avait 17 ou
18 ans il est parvenu rct qui est resté
il a lui tranquillement rabat à jour
sera la grande ville et 15-30 cm de sang
sur la place du taureau s'élève
il les mettait en rampe qui fusillait
[Musique]
je m'amuse
bien
[Musique]
ce matin
oui
fermée mais roland dussault texting
sortait de l'école on à l'elysée
[Musique]
il inventa les pays du monde y naissent
pas aligné sur l'italie et la libye je
ne sais quoi toi et nos médecins
revanche sous la vidéo pour bien revenir
fort des ministres libéraux verts ou le
message était plus optimiste que ça mais
je croyais pas
[Musique]
ces insultes
le 38
en fait l'accord de munich avait fait
une grève générale qui n'asservit
malheureusement à rien et puis 39 alors
une déclaration de guerre le parti
communiste met hors la loi
l'arrestation des dirigeants nous
convenir vague d'arrestations puis après
nous avons eu nous offrir un moment un
refoulement et puis finalement réussi de
l'un à l'autre
est ce que cette année jusqu au 7 allée
assez haut mais finalement on nous a
donné un sursis mais nous a pas rendu
nos cartes de séjour nous sommes restés
semblent quant à pied pour une simple
pied de mettre là depuis donc 39 ans
depuis 59 jusqu'à 42 ont été refoulés en
tant que communiste
c'est sûr on a mon avis qui sont partis
ni un des refoulés mais ils étaient
cueillis à la frontière c'était c'était
le cas de concentration comme c'est pas
la prison
mais j'avais ouais je me souviens
moi j'étais à l'époque regarder la télé
française qui reste à faire on savait
tous
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis venu je suis marylise il ça
fait des années que je suis la rue il
manque certaines entrées savez combien
s'appelait sa fille prennent leurs
marques
moi ça fait soixante dix huit ans que
vous êtes là je vais avoir 90 20 moi
j'ai jamais senti le besoin de demander
la nationalité moi je vivais à bien
j'étais biennoise
on était complètement intègre rien mais
entre temps nous nous à partir de 40 mo
pris contact avec la résistance est là
non ça nous faisait quand même moins
peur parce que vont passer à la
clandestinité un set est plus question
d'aller dans la gueule de mussolini 1,42
petit plus du tout pareil on se
demandait ce que ça allait faire on
sentait que c'était le nazisme tournée
qui était contrôlé plus fascisme italien
voulons continuer la lutte comcom avait
commencé
la culture mame et des jeunes et des
petites robes et un parterre la campagne
les échanger contre commun et petites
routes enfants des machins comme ça
comment trouver rien acheter les gens
étaient contents
jarrier des armes
on nous à porter des armes ne sais pas
d'où elle venait mon père lui pendait
les gresset les enveloppait les intérêts
dans le jardin après on nous disait
qu'il fallait on est sortis en le
amenait un jour avec une camarade dans
ceux du comedd et sata moleskine il y
avait autrefois on portait ça c'était
lourd comme ton les porter à 2 en plein
centre-ville les mêmes et 6,8
heureusement que c'était plié tous des
rêveurs dans la rue on a ramassé sans
vitesse
on a eu peur bien des formes enfin
toujours pire je pense que dans une
certaine mesure on était peut-être même
inconsciente du danger concours parce
qu'ils ont été fusillés pour moins que
ça oui la terre de mon père je plante
mais mes pieds mes petites fleurs d'amis
pour fleurs moi je mets sur la table la
terre un gros bof je me dis bah oui
alors je pense à lui je vis baby aussi
je pouvais y mettre sur la pop moi je la
mets la perse mais je crois qu on passe
outre une chose mais aujourd'hui alors
je vous racontais de l'histoire de mon
frère elle quand il est parti alors on
mettait en danger nous arrête la gestapo
parce qu'il permet des otages moi
j'avais couché chez une amie et mes
parents avaient couché instance 1 dans
une maison et puis le un soir dimanche
soir on revenait tous les dimanches on
allait chercher à manger à la cantine
quand tu vois mon père sur la route nul
jeudi mais vous êtes là oui la maison
elle était tombée alors ils sont venus
toucher au jardin on avait une espèce de
petite baraque mais c'était de la terre
battue mais il capte pleuvait il
pleuvait des couches et sous son
parapluie côté oui c'est pas ma soeur
que j'ai connu
mais ses membres des jeunesses
communistes révèlent comment cela jouera
le banc je côtoie ben moi aussi bon tout
souriant quand le studio waro jardin val
d'oise toit au moment du pacte germano
soviétique
tu t'es tu étais un vélo je me bruit que
fait une bicyclette ne lui a pas si
longtemps vélo à la porte hitler entre
et je me posais des questions parce
qu'il y avait bien sûr c'est un trouble
de rubino public
si l'attenté y avait un changement quel
qu'il soit ça réveille est quand même
les champs la situation est vraiment
éclairci chrono l'allemagne à ce qui est
de la ligne on se lasse a été franc et
voilà les chaussons nous plaire tout en
étant très inquiet sur la suite des
événements parce qu'on savait qu'il
était très puissant et on a eu beaucoup
d'espoir quand on sait d'examen napoléon
ça lui a pas réussi alors hitler ça va
peut-être se repérer le papier comme il
s'était un peu reconstituée en votant
oui on y voyait plus clair puis on était
déjà mais organisé on faisait voter les
gens vous avez des les cas les
hébergeait la libération pour ça a été
aussi un moment difficile où vous avez
invité à la fois difficile parce que
évidemment on apprenait la perte de
copains et en même temps exaltant parce
qu'on était libérés
c'était tellement il fait partie de tout
ce qui est important
césaire n'était en espagne il faisait il
était membre du parti de jeunesse
socialiste unifié et ici il y avait il
s'est formé après la libération ici
c'est fait c'était forme une petite un
petit groupe d'espagnols qui était
communiste on se conduit comme ça d'un
effet après la libération
et puis nous nous sommes mariés en 40
bonjour mon champ ça va marcher vos
chaussures vient chercher mes chaussures
secret oui c'est fait je pense que ça a
moins de prix je vous aime internet
encore tout à fait le rapport
dans cette chronique vous êtes arrivées
n'en avaient débuté la bam avait acheté
les chauffards et bill parents qui ne
vous vous rappelez comme ans et olivier
lamarque moyen-âgeuse surtout pour oui
mais je savais se tournait bien vrai ça
marche et vélo des coûts de réparation
au début c'étaient les talons aiguilles
de règles alors moi je mets là bas au
début ça marchait pas du tout s'il y
avait plein de clients alors et apple
est tapé sur des morceaux de cuivre ou
marivaux fait remarquer tralala et puis
s'il y avait quelqu'un qui mettait le
pied sur trottoir il disait savoir si
c'est un cri quelqu'un qui vient chez
moi dans vosges oui et puis ça a pris on
avait déjà une petite clientèle mais
quand on est venu ici on l'a doublée et
on a travaillé une dizaine d'années mon
mari est tombé malade à 63 il nous
fallait vivre on est et reste on est
resté pendant deux ans sans rien aucune
ressource rien leur emprunt alors on la
vente de la voiture en allant nous en
avons eu quelques petites économies on a
tout bouffé pas de couverture sociale et
des terres décembre il n'y avait rien
pour les appels
c'était une autre époque ça a été
quelque chose d'affreux
[Musique]
il ya mes parents il ya mon frère et mon
mari en tous les cas
il ya tout ce que les permis
je t'aime d'identité pour se faire voir
un cendrier qui m'avait intéressé parce
qu'il vient d'estrémadure qui était mon
mari j'ai mené ma belle soeur ma
belle-soeur alam avait les larmes aux
yeux c'est vrai il est très attaché à
son pays alors je regrette le plus avant
mon mari pour le faire moi alors mon
mari me dit dès qu'on pourra y fera côté
ailleurs faire la connaissance de ma
famille mais lui la dénommant moi je le
parlais la basse au jeu en cours tant
que femme qu il sera magie retournement
alors à 57 les vacances de 57
je suis partie des messages avec les
connaissances de narino oui marie laure
c'est une petite fille timide qui reste
toujours en arrière et tout et on
sentait qu'elle avait besoin de de soin
de prendre des forces alors j'avais posé
la question ma belle-soeur jeudi c'est
si tu veux que je l'amène trois mois
voulait un changement d'ère elle avait
posé la question au docteur claudio
prévu ça peut amener à la petite elle
était toujours prêt par la partie et je
vais amener pied finalement il faut
qu'elle a été ici est bien la plus vive
est retourné deux parents sont venus la
voir plusieurs fois puis après ses
parents sont venus s'établir ici mais
elle a toujours voulu rester chez nous
là aujourd'hui elle est mariée à 8
d'allemagne elle a deux enfants des
grands enfants
s'il faille assez bon alors il faut
garder le doigt dessus on garde ça si
c'est beau comme à lui-même mis non
est-ce que s'affiche à 1
est-ce que tu achètes ça c'est toi qui
me les acheter
moi on les avait apporté de la mafia je
suis pas bon je peux lâcher
ouais tu me racontait que vous aviez
vous aviez une réunion hier à la section
du parti à vienne une réunion oui elle
peut demander les principaux augmentent
ou pour eux vous préparer l' exposition
des livres et alors il y aura le livre
de daniel berger tond fait à huy ha
d'oliviers payèrent la lagune ébrié mois
à venir si le rendement des propositions
de faire des propositions qui fera sa
défaite comme une défiance de
propositions qui nous ont été faits par
la maison des enfants des femmes disent
ou les faux dessine moi j'aurais bien
c'est comme si moi j'aimais bien celle
ci réduit la marque à 9 heures à vienne
sauf que celle-ci a une signification
deux perspectives les autres c'est une
signification de mémoire je me suis bien
intéressé il ya eu un autre cheminement
sur les femmes afghanes j'aurais bien
aimé celle ci je crois qu'elle a été
acceptée
et puis on va surtout et aussi sur les
entrées ambitieux tant de du compte tu
sais tous les événements qui se passe là
c'est là la montée du fascisme en
autriche berlusconi en italie
tout ça c'est inquiétant il ya quand
même de quoi se faire un certain souci
la néo fasciste et il lui ce président
du conseil sous berlusconi et je pense
que rappeler ce qui s'est passé pendant
cette période très difficile dans notre
ville ces tracts pourrait faire
peut-être un débat à la même occasion
avec jean-daniel présentera avec la
signature de son livre
owen le développement des mouvements
fascistes un peu partout way et je pense
qu'il est expliqué comment nous nous
avons lutté contre le fascisme c'est
peut-être pourquoi c'est important
il y avait un balcon qu'avait organisé
les jeunesses communistes et nous sommes
venus c'était quelque chose et ça l'est
beaucoup de succès parce que c'est tout
de suite après les congés payés y avait
une fronde populaire tout ça je dansais
avec des miennes daniel lasserre et à ce
moment là parce que nos pieds devant on
passait juste à la table où il y avait
mes parents il ya une espèce de boule
qui tombe fumantes
il a compris ce que c'était et il a
attrapé cette boule et l'a jeté à
l'extérieur donc là tu vois là par le
bâtiment dans la rue et est tombé dans
la rue et elle avait à peine posé
qu'elle a explosé alors la lumière s'est
éteinte et tout et on a vu à travers y
avait un petit mur
le hangar qui s'enfuyaient à leur daniel
qui était grand sportif qui jeu il a
sauté la barrière élus à courir près et
il est arrivé à la peindre sur le
batteur il allait l'attraper et puis
quand il allait la peindre l'autre s'est
retournée et elle l'a battue en aurait
il aurait dû penser les termes et mais
on ne pensait pas entendre de l'année et
voilà elle l'a battue
je crois que tous avaient soulevé la
france entière le jour des funérailles
la population disait la presse disait
que la population de bienne avait doublé
donc il y avait trente mille personnes
au fédéral
mais ça a été ça a été la première
victime du fascisme
c'est dans les périodes de l'utopie à
cette solidarité ci parle comme ça
puisons notre vie les gens sont pas
pareilles conneries et que quand on est
partis en grève
les ouvriers et il n'y avait pas de quoi
manger pendant huit jours alors il
fallait les aider tout de suite parce
qu'on avait des salaires de misère
et alors qu'on partage et l'amitié de la
cie mais ça change sur les pages jaunes
[Applaudissements]
spécialité qu'il n'ait diversement
vitaly mois que le même plus comment
c'était la marque à la risc os vous
devez penser avant d'y l agence mais
c'est parce que tu baignes déjà dense
est dans cette situation que tu est
révolté que tu te sens la nécessité de
temps bien j'ai mon frère et mon
n'étaient pas les seuls fils de
militants mais il y en avait pas
beaucoup il y en a pas beaucoup et j'en
suis l'exemple des parents les jeunes
qui venaient nous parce que nous voyait
livre nous y suivait notre exemple
c'était pas par contre moi j'ai toujours
été contre ça de dire à quelqu'un vient
avec nous fais ci fais ça non il faut
les laisser qui viennent spontanément
[Musique]
c'est gentil on est vraiment content de
porter en avant l'art n'est pas mal
la pente et lembeye de partout jamar
mars à ces deux sociétés veulent annuler
leurs descendants des communes camarades
sauter l'appareil les musiques la mitre
arrivée grenade me situe mais me sort de
l'ombre à ta place et thomas misa
consoler sur la route
si les compagnons dans la nuit la
liberté où c'est tout
[Musique]
un anniversaire alba voici quelques
piges one et merci pour les histoires
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
e